the premiere episode of Resident Evil
Revelations 2 is an inconsistent
experience that's plagued by glaring
unions but despite its missteps it
commands your attention you will roll
your eyes at poorly written dialogue
rows but there's also moments of pure
tension that raise your pulse and the
mysteries keep piling up until the very
end sometimes it's a moment of gunplay
that feels just right and at others
haunting scenes start accord with your
innermost fears that's not to say it's
rough patches won't stick with you but
episode 1 gets significantly better as
it progresses though revelations 2
starts with a whimper it doesn't waste
any time getting you into the game right
when they are starting to enjoy a swanky
company party Resident Evil
hall-of-famer Claire Redfield and her
co-worker young Moira Burton are
violently kidnapped and shipped off to a
demented penal colony on a remote island
the pair fights who escaped their prison
fending off the reign of mutants known
as the afflicted as they're taunted by a
mysterious overseer Laura's father the
ever memorable Barry Burton from the
original Resident Evil attempts to come
to their rescue with the help of a young
companion he searches the same prison
but the enemies he faces are quite
different acting more like classic
zombies as they shuffle along rather
than the speedy juggernauts that hunt
Claire and Moira this setup affords you
two points of view within the same
nightmare in different gameplay
experiences but not all things are
created equal Barry's act is far
stronger than Claire's not only because
it offers the best moments of tension
but because it does a better job of
using the game's buddy system both Barry
and Claire have young partners by their
side pairing firepower with special
abilities you can switch between one or
the other on the fly and sometimes he
needs you in order to solve simple
environmental puzzles
unfortunately the game hands you
solutions in the form of simple tasks
making these moments feel like chores
rather than puzzle solving opportunities
Moira is asked to point a flashlight
around a room to find a key for example
testing your patience rather than your
intellect
if anything these quandaries feel like
justifications for even having a psychic
unfortunately there are also bigger
problems at foot namely Moira she spouts
vulgarity after vulgarity it's not hard
to take him because it's offensive it's
obvious that she's meant to sound young
and brash
however Maura comes off as an
exaggerated caricature rather than a
realistic portrayal of an immature
teenager outside of a few important plot
points the only helpful thing lawyer
brings to the table is a flashlight I'm
on night duty by the time you meet
Natalia Barry's mysterious companion her
subtle personality comes across as a
breath of fresh air
Natalia is soft-spoken and quietly
confident she's far more useful than
water to able to sneak by enemies
undetected and crawl into tight spaces
if Barry is low on health Natalia is a
solid back up trading head on action for
simple but effective stealth she
presents an interesting contrast because
though she has the potential to be very
effective she's far more vulnerable than
her caretaker goes straight back Natalia
you can tackle the campaign by a local
co-op with a friend but second players
have to come to terms with the fact that
they're playing second fiddle teaming up
as an effective means of getting through
the campaign quickly because you aren't
relying on AI to watch your back and you
have the ability to multitask but the
split-screen view and real-world chatter
can dilute the tension if you're looking
to get scared playing a solo is the only
way to go if you find your trigger
finger inching after beating the first
episode and can't hop in the raid mode
this arcade-like experience pits you
against small armies of enemies in
various environments and you're
encouraged to take advantage of your
firepower more enemies you kill the
better awards you receive often in the
form of additional weapons it's a very
different experience to the main game
especially with us initially drawing
techno soundtrack but it's a fun
diversion that gives you plenty to do
once the rather short campaign comes to
it
though you have to wade through mediocre
puzzles and endure cringe-worthy
dialogue and references to pass games is
almost a clear sandwich Episode one of
Resident Evil Revelations to
successfully entices you to look forward
to the next episode maybe the fact that
it's so short means you don't have time
to grow tired of its antics but perhaps
it commands your attention because it
periodically redeems itself before
stealing the deal with an impactful
cliffhanger with taste of both classic
and modern Resident Evil Revelations 2
seems to have something for everyone but
it would be better served if it was a
little more focused and had a little
less Moira are you okay did they hurt
you